how do you see this kind of media  landscape moving forward because it does  seem like the old guard the dinosaur  media the prostitutes the horror stream  media they're just going down in droves  and I it's it's you know I I hate to  celebrate something negative but it's  good to see a Changing of the Guard  myself look it's it's really good to see  it changing the guard the stuff that you  guys are doing the stuff that other  folks are doing is fantastic because  you're covering issues that people care  about you're talking about things in  depth in a way that people care about  not in a way that some person based in  Washington DC is deciding how to tell  you about the information you are  engaging on it you're having an in-depth  discussion I mean it's it's free it's  open people like to listen to it they're  a part of the conversation